Paul you've also had a quite a classic
bad date yes I did when a couple of them
but one was really bad I was a double
date a buddy of mine and I went out with
two girls many years ago and the girls
didn't I think was pretty quickly
realized they were not that interested
in either one of us and we thought it
would be funny if we just started making
each other laugh and each guy kept
trying to outdo the other guy with just
silly things and when we were driving
home I was driving and I used to have a
jeep it didn't have the doors on it or
roof or anything like that and I was
driving I thought it'd be really funny
if while I was talking to my date who
was writing and the scene next to me if
I just stepped out I started running
alongside the car and I wasn't driving
fast obviously but even when you're
driving slow you can't it's really fast
she was talking some I just stepped out
of my car to run and I hit the pavement
so and I felt the tire kind of swoosh
past my house I looked up and I saw my
car going toward a tree and then it
stopped yeah because the girl that
backed had to jump in the front seat and
put on the emergency brake my hands were
all cut up my hands were torn and I
limped back to the car and they were
ashen-faced and wondered what what did
and then we just drove home very quiet
did you pretended to be in an accident
rather they got it no I thought it'd be
funny it's right honestly there's no
explaining it would be funny if I
remember my my leg really hurt and when
I got home I used to have contact lens
contact lenses I had a contact lens case
and when I got home I took off my pants
and I saw the imprint of left and right
you